We're about to make the best roasted tomato soup
with cheesy garlic bread.
There's just nothing that beats that combination.
So we're gonna start off by making some baguette. So
I add my starter with all of my ingredients to my bowl
and then give it a good knead in my stand mixer.
When the dough is really sticky,
I transfer it to a greased bowl
just to rise for 45 minutes.
After 45 minutes,
I do stretch and folds,
and then let it rest for another 45 minutes
before I form my dough into three little balls.
I then fold them over and form them into little logs
before I put them aside for their final rise.
In the meantime,
I prep my tomato soup.
So I get all of my tomatoes.
I use a few different ones.
I use heirloom tomatoes,
some cherry tomatoes,
and then tomatoes on the vine.
I also had some purple carrots laying around,
so I decided to add those as well.
We can't forget about the onions and the garlic.
And I sprinkle it with some olive oil,
salt, pepper,
and some Rosemary.
While that's roasting in the oven,
I get started on making my butter.
Once my butter is separated from my buttermilk,
I squeezed out all the liquid
and then rinsed it in cold water,
sliced it up,
and put that aside.
Then I swapped out my tomatoes in the oven
for my baguette.
And while those were baking,
I blended Up my tomato soup
and had to run it through a strainer
just to get all the little bits out.
And then I added some miso paste.
Love the combination of miso and tomato.
Then I took the roasted garlic,
squeezed it out,
added it to my butter
alongside some parsley and flaky sea salt,
and spread that all over our fresh baguettes,
topped it with a good amount of cheese,
and there we go.
I was so excited to have this.
There's nothing more comforting to me
than cheesy garlic bread with tomato.